I think humoresque was the winner of the
photo
board and it was the first photo play
award winner because it was the film
that resonated with the audience long
after they left the theater and this was
a time when people saw movies two three
four times a week so to have one that
stayed with them like humoresque did I
think that's what made it so meaningful
I think it's it's stood the test of time
in the sense that in retrospect we can
see that it's a nap the classic mother
love film well I think it's hard for us
to imagine I mean we're so inundated
with information from all sources now
how hard it is for us to imagine being
able to go around the corner and put
your nickel or your dime or your quarter
down and go into the theater and have
these worlds open up to you for the very
first time I mean people who never left
who lived within 10 miles of where
they'd been born spent their whole life
there and all of a sudden they're
introduced to these not just foreign
worlds and cultures and and different
ideas and newsreels for goodness sake
yes there's newspapers and magazines
radio hasn't even come in yet and all of
a sudden on the big screen I mean
there's Gloria Swanson draped in these
jewels and furs and offering a life
where it clearly is sparks the
imagination of an entire generation it
does take a slightly different aesthetic
to watch it because it totally commands
your attention we're so used to now
watching a movie but also you know
making know watching television and you
can get up and go and you can certainly
when you go to theaters I mean people
are talking and doing other things while
they're watching I mean it's inexcusable
but that's what they do and yet silent
films can demand our attention not just
because of the title cards but because
the story is told visually and through
pantomime and I think there's an
incredible story telling lesson in that
so I mean the audiences who aren't in
the business can enjoy this incredible
story telling but people who are in the
business I think up so much to learn
from silent films the visual aspects of
it the way they fill every frame the
close-ups the medium shots everyone is
very very purposeful and the way the
characters and the
actors tell their story primarily
through pantomime is incredible craft
that should be respected and revered
you